welcome to another edition of up with
Sami I'm here with mr. Martin he and now
once again if I lose $100 we'll go
straight out of my pocket to mr. Martin
he all right
same thing we got five minutes on the
clock
it's touchmove it's USC uprated so with
legal moves we'll end the game and that
includes putting a pawn on the back row
okay and now go switching out for a
queen
we're okay all right so you ready for
this mr. Martin
all right well good one
interesting
check out the dead keep it my bishop
hair
what do you do
Oh
all right
the flips back this includes bounty
edition
see if I can see a tactic here alright
here comes them
do I see a tag somebody's calling me
maybe they remember that kind of tell me
what the tactic is here kind of phone a
friend some new message plain t forward
here we go Oh
we're just trying this although it's
that with my phone friend said it's good
enough
one of that
before yes
if I don't get serious quicker than we
have hundred bucks
scary stuff scary stuff
laughs Walter defense all right sounds
good I like stuff to win a game though
when you're playing moves like that
we'll see but you never know
Oh
should I get my check Chuck let's get
much
maybe I'll get my paint clothes nice
knowing he's on the prowl tonight is on
the prowl
he's got a pass pulling up
yeah marna played very well much better
than i expected of them much much better
do you want to play again or do you want
to say oh I try or play cards looking
for a way out
if you can ever wake a match by
forfeiture
all right so you guys are planning to
Moria if you go to the full lip - two
more yeah unless obviously Martin gets
the better of me
I need this hundred dollars for the
casino tonight okay Martha take it easy
okay how much should I play III now or
should I wait till after I get my fish
Oh big one of one of the strip
all right rise up in a resume
everybody's in pin
so beautiful there's a visa
there's a please
mysterious things are playing about
delay or increment a mirror stare
through this third why you be scared
here we go that's where she wants to be
all right now it's time to just try to
get into up to a better game here
the endgame
maybe
scary but I can't all right as ever
thanks oh how did I not see this move
like and I know where this is the move
that's gonna bring me
hmm yeah yeah even on mark two roots and
when you're calling the cursor when you
know that is when you know
this is why I always tell my students
don't play e6 or III get your bishops
out got better my bishops are
and unfortunate his rook is stuck so I
do not have to what take it at this
point let's just be safe
another Chuck
insurances entered the building
if adjourn would have got here an hour
ago we could have seen out see me lose
the hundred now most likely this is what
I'm playing for adjourned but I like my
chances
make it up let's make it a prom for
asking
yeah I'm not gonna like this move Martin
not gonna like it
haha Martin Martin
should be a plane Jefferson Starship no
way out right now what's that place that
is it over
yeah over for you okay it's official
it's over free at home it should be
playing no way out okay all right and
you get day off
you got the white Jesus for the finale
okay oh yeah going off in serious hair
get serious all right so this is it this
is it this is his last chance to win
$100 cash no pressure
interesting so I just trying something
different this time I wonder if he knows
the trick
I gotta play hope says the whole day
doesn't know the trick he doesn't judge
or knows the trick there's nothing else
all about it
I don't know if those moves are good or
bad but
castles three huh I cannot retreat to
where I want to go in half retreat to
where
and that gives me the opportunity to
train
not really
her
let's just do it let's calculate a busy
man busy man busy busy
just go for it
okay I'll do the same thing I like that
he's Marta is not amused
that's my
okay little spirits will stare it's a
little scary I can't resist trade off I
can't Oh interesting
that would actually be a funny move and
this will go to uh River City tonight
so I'm losing one we're in the other so
I recognize take glory than that alright
thanks for cooking mark another
fantastic flip spouting another success
now 10 and oh nine mo in those games